Republicans are in a desperate panic to suppress
an audio recording of the Texas speaker of
the house talking about a political hit list,
which is just ringing sort of inappropriate
or out of touch given the constant gun violence
problems that we're dealing with in the United
States.
There is a recording that was made by a right
wing activists, Michael Sullivan, of his meeting
with Texas House Speaker.
Dennis Bonnen.
So understand this is all right wingers.
It's a right wing activists, right-wing Texas
speaker of the house.
Sullivan has a pack and Bonnen gave him a
hit list of people to target in the primaries
in Texas.
Okay.
In the Republican primaries, Republicans have
heard the tape and they are doing everything
that they can, everything they can think of
everything they can imagine to stop its release.
Texas Republican Steve Toth called it quote,
damaging and embarrassing.
And there's actually two layers here that
we should be talking about.
The first layer is this imagery of a hitlist.
They couldn't be more out of touch.
Mitch McConnell's campaign recently did something
similar.
They tweeted a picture of a graveyard with
the names of political opponents, including
McConnell's primary opponent.
Um, a, a rather a, uh, McConnell's general
election challenger, Amy McGrath, a photo-shopped
onto headstones.
They just can't help themselves.
So the violent imagery is issue number one.
The second issue is that the Republicans don't
want their own infighting made public.
This is a list of Republicans to target in
primaries that was assembled by Republicans.
So obviously for both reasons, I want this
thing released.
I would love to hear this tape and we should
do everything we can to get it released, but
then let's zoom out just a little bit that
this is happening in Texas specifically is
panicking Republicans nationally because Texas
is one of the few single states that is keeping
Republicans in control nationally.
If Texas stops being reliably red and becomes
a purple state, either purple in terms of
its representation in Washington DC at the
national level or purple in terms of its Internal
House of Representatives, at some point in
the future, Republicans may really suffer
nationally and potentially even be effected
for a generation if that were to happen.
So the Republicans are particularly panicked
because it's Texas.
Now, I've talked before about how the left
really cannot fall for Donald Trump's attempt
to divide and distract.
For example, when we talked about his foam
ending, the divide between Nancy Pelosi and
the squad and pumping up that infighting,
we don't want to allow Donald Trump to divide
the left in this way.
In this case, we want this Republican Texas
in fighting to grow as much as possible for
the same reason that it is going to divide
them and potentially hurt them.
Now let me get to something else.
You know how Democrats handle sexual assault
very differently than Republic Republicans
handle sexual assault by members of their
own respective parties.
When Anthony Wiener was caught in a sexting
with a, with a minor and doing all, all sorts
of other stuff, who on the left was defending
wiener?
I don't remember anyone defending wiener when
Al Franken was caught, uh, caught Democrats
probably went too far in demanding that he
resigned.
The left is not only different when it comes
to sexual assault by members of their own
party.
The left is different on this cover up stuff.
And what I mean by that is if I found out
today that Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
or whoever had been caught on a recording
saying something disgusting or damaging or
counter to the values that I believe the left
should espouse, I would want it public immediately.
I would want to hear it.
I would want to comment on it and I would
want to get truly problematic people out of
the movement because they hurt my movement.
There are enclaves of this blind worship of
the left around some 2020 candidates, which
I've talked about.
I won't name them, but most of the left would
not be trying to cover up something equivalent
to this.
We would want it out.
We would want the people dealt with and we
would want to move on with people that we
feel good about.
They are really different than us.
Okay?
I want to win, but I want to win without stooping
to their level.
Okay?
So I've said before, listen, heckling a politician
in public in a nonviolent way.
This is okay and we've gotta be okay with
it.
But I don't want to stoop to their tactics
to win, even though I do want to win.
And that's why it makes this so complicated.
Let's hope, at least in the interim, in the
immediate, is that the audio is released,
and I will be talking about this and much
more tonight during a live twitch event at
6:30 PM eastern.
I hope you'll join me at twitch.tv/david Pacman
and we can talk about this or anything else
you want to.
It should be a great event.
Uh, make sure you're following me on Twitter
at de Pacman.
And while you're there, follow the David Pakman
show on Twitter at David Pakman show.
We will take a quick break and be back with
much more, a lot of really good stuff on case
program